aujourd'hui j'ai 91 ans j'aurais été
heureuse d'avoir un petit mot de toi un
petit coup de fil ce petit dessin pour
te montrer l'époque heureuse où tu étais
ma petite fille mon amour pour toi est
inchangé il est très fort et immortel
cette lettre n'est jamais parvenue à sa
destinataire
pas fier j'ai obéi la règle d'obéissance
aujourd'hui oui je m'en veux
Guru suicide collectif offrande nous
avons tous en tête des images des
articles des témoignages que nous avons
lu sur les sectes mais il reste
tellement de mystère je découvre deux
personnes qui ont été victimes de dérive
sectaires la mère de Magalie a pris la
tête de amour et miséricorde
magalie a assisté à sa transformation et
s'est laissée embrigader
Jean-Luc aussi est devenu adepte d'une
secte
comment pourquoi
à travers leurs histoires je vais tenter
de comprendre à quoi ressemble notre vie
une fois qu'un autre on a pris le
contrôle
je m'appelle Jean-Luc Barbier j'ai 61
ans j'ai été victime d'une secte je
m'appelle magaliebreux j'ai 30 ans et
j'ai été victime d'un groupe à dérive
sectaire
Jean-Luc Barbier mag
Ali pendant 10 ans
Italie se psychique
lui a été adepte de la scientologie
elle a été sous l'emprise de sa mère qui
a fondé un groupe de prière dénoncé pour
ses pratiques sectaires
[Musique]
dans une autre vie Jean-Luc Barbier
était saxophoniste un jazzman Suisse
renommé dans les années 70 mais
aujourd'hui il sort rarement son
instrument de son étui
qui reprend le dessus
et voilà
Jean-Luc ne joue plus depuis des années
car il souffre d'une inflammation du
larynx un mâle développé dans les années
80 à l'époque il ne l'a pas soigné car
il était scientologue et c'était
interdit par la secte
j'ai eu un premier contact avec la
Scientologie en 77 c'est avec une
musicienne
américaine qui était à Genève installé à
Genève et qui annonçait une nouvelle
thérapie qui venait des États-Unis
[Musique]
Jean-Luc n'est pas convaincu par les
écrits de Ron Hubbard qui est le
fondateur de l'organisation et il en
reste là mais deux ans plus tard un
événement le traumatisme l'incendie de
son immeuble à Genève et je me suis
retrouvé en milieu de la nuit
dans la fumée j'ai juste réussi à sortir
j'ai échappé à la mort le plancher s'est
effondré au moment où je suis sorti
Jean-Luc est perturbé par cet événement
est fragilisé par un récent divorce il
pense trouver dans la Scientologie la
confiance qu'il a perdue
il passe alors un test de personnalité
la première étape du recrutement des
adeptes et le résultat est douloureux
ils m'ont tout de suite dit qu'en tant
qu'artiste allait pas du tout j'avais
vraiment quelque chose qui est très
faible c'est la communication et puis
que j'allais à Marwin quoi si je
continue comme ça ma carrière serait
foutue quoi alors je suis pris un peu
peur
Jean-Luc s'inscrit donc au cours de
communication ici
au centre de la Scientologie de Genève
vous apprenez en fait à perdre votre
caractère naturel on vous fait des
exercices pendant des heures vous devez
répondre Oui bien ok sans émotion et
vous devez aussi apprendre lorsqu'on
vous harcèle et je le dis bien lorsqu'on
voit seul c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
quelqu'un devant vous je vais je vais
vous le dire c'est quelqu'un qui est là
qui dit d'abord
[Musique]
et vous devez rester devant calme
détendu avec un harcèlement et vous
réussissez cet exercice jusqu'à ce que
vous ne bougez pas le moindre cil
pour conditionner mentalement les
adeptes les scientologues utilisent une
drôle de machine l'électrometre
Jean-Luc a participé à de nombreuses
séances avec cet appareil
alors l'électrometre de la Scientologie
qui
est censé
mesurer
les charges mentales
l'aiguille de l'électromet
re et agir au réaction
[Musique]
S très poussé par exemple en pose une
question pense à ton papa voilà il y a
une réaction comme ça puis après on pose
une question pense à ta maman voilà la
réaction était plus forte alors on va
maintenant demander est-ce que ta maman
cache quelque chose envers toi est-ce
que ta maman a fait quelque chose envers
toi etc etc on va on va vraiment creuser
creuser creuser si à l'imagine par
exemple que sa mère je sais pas par
exemple la fait des tentatives
d'avortement sur elle s'imagine donc
comme l'électromet soit disant trouver
la vérité et bien elle va commencer voir
un rapport très difficile avec sa maman
voir à avoir un ordre de la Scientologie
de couper les liens avec sa maman ça
détruit les familles ça induit des faux
souvenirs ça peut provoquer des névroses
des psychos c'est dangereux
dodo Jean-Luc devient donc un
scientologue assidu en tant qu'artiste
il s'inscrit à des cours aux célébrités
Center de la Scientologie à Paris
il pense s'y suivre des cours de musique
mais ça n'est pas le cas c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui n'a pas avoir avec le
domaine artistique mais plus avoir avec
même je dirais comment un artiste peut
contacter des personnalités politiques
comment il doit lui parler de la
Scientologie c'est un cours presque de
public relation qu'on fait aussi dans
ses cours pour artistes plus je parlais
en fait de Scientologie à mes amis plus
sa moto disons je
me auto hypnotisait Jean-Luc est
désormais un scientologue recruteur il
embrigade de nouveaux adeptes parmi ses
amis sa femme également s'intéressera à
la Scientologie mais son terrain de
chasse préféré ce sont les rives du lac
Léman à Genève c'était vraiment un lieu
où la propagande de Scientologie pouvait
se faire très facilement et aussi c'est
un exercice de vente qu'on était obligé
de faire au début ça me rebutait un
petit peu de d'aller vers les jambes
leur poser des questions demander ce
qu'il pensait de la société par rapport
à la drogue s'il y avait pas trop de
drogue etc et en fait on apprend à
manipuler les gens et ça c'était mon
terrain de d'entraînement en fait
la pêche aux adeptes était plutôt bonne
à l'époque d'après Jean-Luc les trois
quarts des gens étaient sensibles à son
prosélytisme en faveur de la
Scientologie
Jean-Pierre Jouglas vous êtes ancienne
avocat spécialiste des sectes quels sont
les méthodes employées par les
organisations sectaires pour embrigader
de nouveaux adeptes les méthodes sont à
peu près universelles dans les groupes
sectaires c'est-à-dire que le premier
temps c'est une période de séduction qui
commence par un contact avec un individu
qui est membre d'un groupe secteur qui
est adepte qui le dit pas et qui met en
place une relation amicale une fois
cette mise en confiance une mise en
place le groupe va pouvoir être présenté
au futur adeptes et là la période de
séduction qui est la plus agréable pour
l'adepte va pouvoir commencer c'est à
dire qu'on va expliquer à l'adepte que
le groupe l'attendait depuis une
éternité depuis des générations enfin
depuis des siècles donc on va lui
montrer les choses sous le meilleur jour
c'est le narcissisme qui va être nourri
chez chez le futur adepte une fois cette
période mise en place la période de
séduction va arriver une période un peu
plus délicate à vivre qui va être la
période de le début de la manipulation
c'est à dire une période où on va
commencer à révéler une mission pour le
futur adepte on va lui révéler le
travail qui va faire dans le groupe
l'utopie du groupe ce projet
extraordinaire sans lequel il peut pas y
avoir d'adhésion un groupe
et puis ce n'est qu'après cette période
de là si l'adepte a mordu à la maison
que il pourra rentrer dans la dernière
étape qui va être la période de la
suggettissement à proprement parler
c'est à dire que on va demander à
l'adepte d'obéir à des règles qui vont
être les règles posées par le groupe
[Musique]
dans les années 80 Jean-Luc est un
scientologue convaincu mais il ignore
encore que cette endoctrinement aura des
conséquences graves sur sa santé et sur
sa vie professionnelle
[Musique]
donc surtout tu le claques pas d'un coup
il faut pas de jaune dans le blanc
voilà très bien tu vois du coup il
descend tout seul non mais voilà
30 ans elle est maire de 3 enfants c'est
notamment grâce à eux qu'elle a tenu le
coup après sa sortie du groupe amour et
miséricorde fondé par sa mère c'était il
y a 5 ans heureusement que je les avais
parce que parce que c'était une période
noire et que si je les avais pas eu
j'aurais je pense mis fin à mes jours
j'aurais pas supporté c'est ça a été une
chance de les avoir et en même temps
heureusement qu'ils étaient là
magalie a vécu 10 ans dans la communauté
amour et miséricorde l'histoire de ce
groupe commence quelques jours avant le
15 août 1996
[Applaudissements]
une amie de ma mère l'appelle en lui
disant que la légende dit qu'il y a une
dame blanche qui apparaît qui
apparaîtrait dans les bois de Plombières
les Dijons à côté de Dijon
à minuit une fois par an cette dame
blanche apparaît le soir du 15 août
Magalie accompagne donc sa mère Eliane
une mère qu'elle n'appelle plus
aujourd'hui que par son prénom la
première fois on est un groupe d'une
petite dizaine de personnes
Eliane s'arrête ici on est tous
attroupés autour d'elle elle nous dit
qu'elle voit quelque chose elle nous
demande à nous est-ce que vous voyez
quelque chose donc tout le monde lui
répond que non
elle reste là un peu
hébété devant quelque chose qu'elle
verrait
et elle dit oui à trois reprises dans un
silence
un silence un silence extrême et
qu'on a peur quand même on se demande
bien ce qu'elle voit ça
donc pas bien entendu on la croit et
puis on lui dit qu'on reviendra avec
elle
[Musique]
cette catholique fervente et même très
précise celle-ci apparaîtrait chaque
mois à minuit 6 dans la nuit du 15 au 16
la nouvelle se répand dans les groupes
de prière et très vite ils sont des
dizaines à accompagner Éliane dans les
bois tout de suite il y a un engouement
autour des lianes qui fait que
très très vite elle est très importante
elle est devenue quelqu'un de de très
très important parce que elle donne la
bonne parole que la Sainte Vierge lui
donnerai donc c'est devenu quand même
bijou quelque chose qu'il faut choyer
Eliane fascine les fidèles qu'il
accompagne aux apparitions et elle y
prend goût
cette attention comportait à ma mère
pour qu'elle n'est pas froid pour
qu'elle ne soit fatigue pas pour que a
commencé à la mettre dans une un
engrenage un peu
de qui l'a habitué à ce qu'on prenne
soin d'elle il faut prendre soin d'elle
et en fait
cette attention qu'elle avait le 15 tous
les mois ne lui suffisait plus fallait
que ce soit comme ça continuellement
quelques mois après les premières
apparitions les fidèles se rassemblent
régulièrement dans cette maison où vit
la famille de Magalie selon la jeune
femme certains fidèles habiteraient même
ici
Eliane est au centre de cette communauté
dont les membres se coupent
progressivement de leur famille
[Musique]
et au fur et à mesure comme ça il y a un
en jouant avec les sentiments en jouant
avec la personnalité de chacun et les
blessures de chacun elle a arrivée à
faire le ménage autour de tout le monde
de tout le monde que ce soit Marie que
ce soit femme que ce soit enfant oncle
tant de cousins n'importe quoi elle a
fait le ménage
[Musique]
amour et miséricorde l'association qui
rassemble les fidèles autour d'Eliane
est fondée en l'an 2000 isolement
soumission ce mouvement qui prétend être
un simple groupe de prière présente
rapidement les caractéristiques d'une
dérive sectaire
Marie Drion vous êtes vice-présidente de
Luna de fille qui regroupe les
associations de victimes de secte ça
peut paraître simple comme question mais
comment on se rend compte qu'on est
victime de sectes beaucoup sont
interpellés par une des différences
entre les comportements des dirigeants
et puis les principes que ces dirigeants
entre autres prônent et oblige à suivre
et qui parfois sont quand même il y a un
grand écart entre les deux si vous
voulez entre le principe et puis son
application ça c'est une des choses
que moi j'ai entendu assez souvent
disait il faisait vraiment pas ce mais
ça a mis très longtemps à se mettre en
place pour d'autres ça a été que à un
moment l'attitude de du mouvement a été
vraiment tellement inhumaine ou
tellement forte dans la dérive si vous
voulez que là leurs yeux se sont ouverts
mais c'est quand même un processus qui
se fait pas d'un seul coup
et qui est long pour certains très longs
et des personnes qui sont restées 30 ans
dans un mouvement sectaire
au début des années 2000 Magalie Bru est
encore une fidèle disciple de sa mère
elle ignore alors qu'une rencontre
décisive va bientôt changer sa vie
[Musique]
au début des années 80 Jean-Luc Barbier
est devenu un scientologue model témoin
de cette métamorphose Fabienne Boula
c'est une amie qu'il connaît depuis
longtemps elle tient aujourd'hui un
commerce à Lausanne à l'époque elle a vu
Jean-Luc changer radicalement de
personnalité il a écouté plus alors que
même maintenant tu viens tu me demandes
comment vont mes enfants comment dans le
magasin et là tu me demandais comment ça
allait au travail ou comme ça là c'était
fini comme bonjour comment tu vas moi je
c'était je nous fais peut-être même plus
nous que je nous les scientologues nous
on pense ça c'est vrai que combien de
fois on m'a reproché ça et je n'écoutais
pas c'était toujours en Scientologie le
réflexe de dire ces gens ne comprennent
pas ce que je vis ce que ce qu'est la
Scientologie c'est toujours c'est
toujours ah c'est-à-dire que
soi et puis surtout tu vois ils te font
rêver comme tu l'as dit il te faut rêver
que tu vas devenir ceci cela j'avais pas
du tout l'impression de changer de
personnalité j'ai l'impression de venir
plus moi-même
mais en fait j'étais en train de venir
plus un scientologue mais ça je le
voyais pas
Jean-Luc s'isole dans sa bulle et
progresse dans la hiérarchie de la
Scientologie mais pour approfondir ses
connaissances il doit suivre un nouveau
programme
le programme de purification
consiste à prendre des mégadoses de
vitamines et faire des très longues
séances de sauna de trois quatre heures
avec des courtes interruptions on peut
prendre un peu de verre un peu d'eau
fraîche mais vraiment c'est on vous êtes
vraiment sur le grill quoi puis moi il y
a eu un phénomène qui s'est passé c'est
que j'ai commencé à avoir des
inflammations très fortes Jean-Luc
souffre d'une inflammation à la gorge
mais au lieu de consulter un médecin il
fait confiance aux scientologues pour le
soigner
donc ils m'ont dit on va continuer
autant de mai encore plus et ça fait
qu'augmenter évidemment mais mon
irritations de la gorge et le résultat
j'avais vraiment plus la possibilité de
jouer de mon instrument ça me faisait
mal et j'étais conditionné aussi pour ne
pas aller voir chez le médecin si vous
demandez de l'aide à un médecin
c'est mal vu en Scientologie c'est
discréditer la puissance des techniques
hubardiennes le mal qui frappe Jean-Luc
devient chronique la mort dans l'âme il
arrête sa carrière de musicien et
c'était vraiment dur c'était vraiment je
pense que j'étais entré en dépression
c'est sûr mais évidemment je ne voyais
pas de dépression je voyais encore
l'espoir d'être guéri par la
Scientologie je rêvais encore
complètement
Jean-Luc Barbier se reconvertit alors
dans la peinture il ouvre des ateliers
et donne des cours à des dizaines
d'élèves c'est un succès mais la
Scientologie s'immisce petit à petit
dans la gestion de son entreprise
il me demandait régulièrement des
comptes et ils m'ont même
juger dans un tribunal scientologue où
j'ai dû aller j'ai dû me rendre en
Suisse allemande
devant un juge qui sort de l'homme qui
m'a dit
vous devez avoir un officier
scientologue d'éthique c'est le nom
technique qui va contrôler votre
entreprise dans votre entreprise
à la même époque Jean-Luc commence à
verser d'importantes sommes d'argent à
l'organisation
j'ai commencé à faire des chèques à non
plus finir et là c'était plus des 2000
francs par année ça passait c'est vite
passé à des 20 000
j'ai des chèques que j'ai fait de 30000
dollars
[Musique]
au total
sa femme et lui ont versé près de 200000
euros à la Scientologie en 1989 il est
incité à suivre des cours réservés à une
élite de scientologues aux États-Unis il
espère que c'est le son lui permettront
de soigner son inflammation ce sont des
cours secrets ou
on met ce qu'on veut c'est à dire pour
une personne comme moi qui avait ce
problème
on lui dit que c'est coco vont
financières vont résoudre ces problèmes
Jean-Luc Barbier passe 5 mois à
Clearwater en Floride dans l'un des plus
grands centres de Scientologie au monde
c'est là qu'il commence à douter de son
engagement
je découvre que il s'agit d'absurdité et
de séances d'exorcisme où on est censé
avoir des petits esprits collés sur le
corps et
par télépathie on communique avec ces
esprits et on leur pose la question pour
savoir à quoi il s'identifie et quand on
a posé cette question il répondent par
télépathie et vous dites en gros je t'ai
reconnu tu es une poussière qui se prend
pour un maux de gorge ou des trucs comme
ça vous voyez ça se croise là j'ai
compris que je m'étais fait piéger et là
je me suis dit il faut que je parte au
plus vite Jean-Luc décide donc de
s'enfuir accessoires même il réserve un
taxi et attend la nuit
une heure du matin je passe par les
cuisines discrètement avec ma grosse
valise et je prends le je passe par
dessus une grande grille et je fais le
mur en quelque sorte et le taxi était là
et direction aéroport directement avec
une entrée dans l'hôtel catastrophique
je suis en pleurs dans ma chambre je
regarde la fenêtre si je peux sauter par
la fenêtre pour me suicider
mais avant de me suicider je dis à ma
femme excusez-moi
et ma femme je lui dis écoute
je me suis dit c'est gaillard il va
avoir affaire
ils vont avoir affaire à moi ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est dégueulasse
Jean-Luc rentre des États-Unis
bouleversé avec le sentiment d'avoir
gâché sa vie là je me réveille mais
c'est un cauchemar je suis en plein
cauchemar c'est vraiment l'explosion
dans la tête quoi tout est tout est tout
est en morceaux par terre tout est par
terre tout est à reconstruire tout est
foutu
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il est difficile de sortir
d'une secte une fois qu'on a pris
conscience qu'on y est en fait ah oui
c'est très difficile très très difficile
alors on peut distinguer quand même de
deux catégories un peu différentes c'est
ce qui sont nés et qui ont été élevés
dans une secte parce que ils n'ont pas
vu autre chose donc ce qui va peut-être
les motiver à sortir c'est au moment où
c'est souvent à l'adolescence et puis
jeunes adultes où ils vont rencontrer
vraiment d'autres modèles
qu'il réussissent aussi bien si ça se
trouve et surtout qui ont d'autres
interprétations de la vie ou qui
remettent en question leur propre leur
propre histoire à eux et leurs propres
vision du monde et puis ceux qui y sont
rentrés alors qu'ils avaient déjà eu une
vie hors de secte si vous voulez et qui
ont
des points de comparaison avec avec leur
histoire d'avant et pour lesquels il va
s'agir cette fois-ci de récupérer le fil
de leur propre histoire si vous voulez
mais
dans les deux cas c'est une épreuve
énorme parce que il va y avoir de
quitter un groupe de quitter des
certitudes donc de se retrouver
éventuellement seul de retrouver des
gens qui vous ont parfois avant signaler
que ce que vous faisiez ou ce dans quoi
vous étiez pas normal et donc accepter
ce regard donc il va y avoir de
l'angoisse de la peur parce que le
mouvement sectaire a toujours toujours
ça fait partie du sectarisme si vous
voulez de dire que l'extérieur est un
risque
ruiner en mauvaise santé Jean-Luc
Barbier sombre dans la dépression
c'est grâce au dessin et à la musique
qu'il va trouver les ressources pour se
battre
[Musique]
4 ans après la première apparition de la
Vierge le groupe amour et miséricorde a
déménagé dans le Jura près de Dole comme
le montre ses images filmées par un
adepte la communauté passe des nuits
entières à prier autour des lianes elle
entend toujours des voix
il y avait une voix qui chante avec moi
en même temps et c'était simplement
Jésus alors à chaque fois qu'on chante
cette chambre cette chanson en langue
Jésus chante avec nous une quinzaine de
fidèles vit dans ce chalet et dans des
caravanes sur un terrain clos à l'abri
des regards
un cercle plus large habite à
l'extérieur et rejoint le groupe tous
les weekends un groupe entièrement au
service des lianes
on la serre comme une reine la journée
mais la nuit aussi la nuit on dort fort
le téléphone allumé si Eliane décide de
n'importe quoi un plat de pâtes au
milieu de la nuit on se lève pour faire
des pâtes à Eliane
si Eliane décide que cette nuit ben
c'est une nuit d'insomnie elle va
réveiller la caravane d'à côté ben je
peux pas dormir tu viens de tenir
compagnie donc on tient compagnie alien
toute la nuit ils viennent à mal aux
jambes on va réveiller la caravane d'en
face pour se faire masser les jambes
mais elle réveille deux ou trois
personnes dans la nuit pour venir la
servir selon Magalie Eliane se comporte
alors comme une sorte de gourou ou
plutôt une gourelle le moindre de ses
caprices doit être satisfait par ses
fidèles on prend les catalogues par
correspondance et puis on dit qu'un
petite sœur je vais je vais t'offrir des
vêtements choisis ce que tu veux tout ce
que tu veux je te l'offre et donc ben on
envoie l'échec on fait des cartes bleues
150 euros par ci 200 euros par là 300
par là et on rhabille Éliane
les adeptes d'amour et miséricorde se
contrôlent les uns les autres sous
l'autorité des lianes chaque membre est
surveillé par un binôme
[Applaudissements]
si un des deux binômes va passer un coup
de téléphone donc il faut qu'il soit
derrière pour savoir à qui l'appelle
s'il va à la poste il faut absolument
que le binôme soit là pour savoir à qui
est l'envoyer un courrier on est on se
surveille comme ça tous on se surveille
on se dénonce les uns les autres vers
Eliane
l'isolement des membres de la communauté
est totale selon ses dires Magalie
aurait par exemple été chargée par sa
mère de détourner les lettres envoyées
par les familles des adeptes un délit
passible d'un an d'emprisonnement et de
45 000 euros d'amende
elle a gardé les courriers les plus
marquants comme ces cartes envoyées par
la mer d'une fidèle aujourd'hui j'ai 91
ans j'aurais été heureuse d'avoir un
petit mot de toi un petit coup de fil ce
petit dessin pour te montrer l'époqueuse
où tu étais ma petite fille mon amour
pour toi est inchangé il est très fort
et immortel cette lettre n'est jamais
parvenue à sa destinataire
je suis pas fier j'ai obéi la règle
d'obéissance
aujourd'hui oui je m'en veux
c'est moche
quand un fidèle enfin les règles du
groupe il est traduit devant un tribunal
présidé par Éliane d'après Magalie c'est
elle et elle seule qui sanctionne la
personne mise en cause elle est isolée
dans un appartement
sur sur Dijon ou aux alentours au pain
il y a l'eau sans que personne ne
l'appelle c'est strictement interdit
d'appeler cette personne pour son
repentir quel prix qu'elle retrouve la
paix dans son cœur et qu'elle retrouve
l'obéissance donc elle est au pain et à
l'eau et elle jeûne jusqu'à ce qu'elle y
a une juge que ça y est c'est bon elle a
elle a elle a fait sa peine ça y est
donc ça peut durer deux jours comme
trois jours comme 5 jours comme une
semaine elle est complètement ostracée
du groupe
Magalie participe à ses séances de
justice collective elle est à la fois
victime et complice involontaire des
agissements de sa mère
mais en 2002 elle rencontre Éric qui
n'appartient pas à la communauté elle se
marie avec lui trois ans plus tard
Eric porte un regard critique sur amour
et miséricorde et il lui fait prendre
conscience des dérives sectaires du
groupe
Eliane ordonne alors à Magali de le
quitter
ma mère voulait que je parte ce soir là
vous voulez que je divorce tu divorce il
est pas fait pour toi il t'a rendu
méchante il t'a rendu mal honnête il te
rend maigre il te rend vraiment pas bien
tu dois partir et donc elle a joué au
chantage affectif en disant écoute c'est
lui au moins
c'est mon mari
en raison de son choix magalie est
expulsé par sa mère de cette communauté
où elle a passé 10 ans
elle le vit très mal
c'était une descente aux enfers j'ai
perdu ma mère
j'ai perdu ma mère j'ai perdu tous mes
amis
j'étais seul au monde seul au monde avec
quelque part entre guillemets juste mon
mari et mes enfants et c'était quelque
part pas suffisant
c'était pas suffisant il manquait cette
vie que j'avais ces gens autour de moi
mes amis ma famille mes frères mes sœurs
mes parents enfin j'avais plus rien quoi
j'étais perdue
Marie Drion est-ce qu'on peut retrouver
une vie normale après avoir passé une
longue période au sein d'une secte voilà
faudrait déjà peut-être définir ce que
c'est qu'une vie normale c'est à dire
que heureusement on a la possibilité
d'avoir des vies très différentes mais
on peut retrouver on va dire une vie
autonome c'est à dire reprendre le fil
de son histoire
personnelle avec un choix de modèle qui
n'est plus le modèle unique de la secte
oui on peut mais c'est très long c'est
douloureux on a besoin d'aide ça c'est
sûr on a besoin d'entourage parce qu'on
va se retrouver seul on va se retrouver
souvent sans moyens et devant des
problèmes à la fois matériel et
psychologique très important ce qu'on en
garde forcément des séquelles mais comme
d'une expérience grave dans la vie que
ce soit une maladie ou que ce soit un
deuil ou que ce soit quoi que ce soit de
graves on les fasse pas de sa vie mais
il se trouve que là en plus
vu les techniques d'emprise et les
techniques psychologiques qu'on a
aujourd'hui qui sont quand même qui nous
cessé de se développer qui ont toujours
existé mais qui l'ont censé de se
développer et d'être théorisés un peu
ces choses dire
l'emprise est profondément ancrée dans
la personnalité donc longtemps après
les réflexes qui ont été insufflés comme
ça les les peurs les anxiété les mots
clés parfois si vous voulez vont faire
leur effet oui donc les angoisses la
culpabilité vont être très longues à
évacuer
rejeté par sa mère après avoir été l'une
de ses fidèles
magaliebreux va bientôt devenir sa plus
farouche adversaire
[Musique]
après sa sortie de la Scientologie
Jean-Luc Barbier a renoué avec la
musique le piano comme remède
l'improvisation en guise de libération
quand on traverse une période comme
celle de la Scientologie qui consiste à
carrément avoir le cerveau lavé à être
complètement dans un monde complètement
irréel le fait de d'avoir un instrument
comme celui-ci ça permet de jouer avec
d'autres personnes ça permet de
retrouver des contacts et puis au niveau
disons de thérapeutique c'est vrai que
le piano est quelque chose de très riche
et qui qui aide à sortir complètement de
ce monde sectaire fermé c'était vraiment
une destruction totale de de moi de mon
entreprise de ma famille etc donc c'est
vrai
on a besoin de trouver une manière de
sortir de là de ce de cet enfer quoi
[Musique]
et de la Scientologie Jean-Luc décide de
contre-attaquer il porte plainte contre
la secte malgré les pressions et les
menaces dont il fait l'objet
j'ai déposé le plainte pour contrainte
et
usure extorsion et atteinte à la santé
et en fait au final le procureur de
Genève monsieur bertosa a estimé que on
pouvait pas déterminer exactement la
responsabilité de chacun des quatre
dirigeants de la Scientologie qui
s'était succédé à Genève durant mon
parcours et il a classé l'affaire pour
moi ça a été un sentiment de Total
injustice et d'incompréhension totale de
la justice de ce que c'est que la
l'emprise secteur malgré le non-lieu
prononcé par la justice Jean-Luc
n'arrête pas son combat il lance une
pétition pour faire interdire la
présence des scientologues sur le marché
de Delémont dans le Jura Suisse c'est
sur cette place qu'ils viennent
régulièrement faire du prosélytisme
bonjour
Gilles on s'est pas vu souvent
le maire de l'époque s'est laissé
convaincre
et lorsqu'une démarche politique peut
accompagner un témoignage comme celui de
Monsieur Barbier je crois que on doit
vraiment y veiller et faire en sorte que
on met un halte-la à certaines pratiques
de l'église de scientologie
[Musique]
le maire a donc interdit la présence des
scientologues sur le marché lorsqu'un
député et Mr prend une telle décision
pour toutes les victimes ça apportait de
symboles parce que c'est très rare
d'avoir ce courage il y a eu quelques
motions ici ou là dans certains cantons
mais jusqu'à l'interdiction prononcer
c'est vraiment rare donc c'était un acte
courageux qui a vraiment aidé toute la
cause
malgré sa lutte acharnée contre la
Scientologie Jean-Luc Barbier reste
hanté par un sentiment de culpabilité
notamment à l'égard des adeptes qui la
recruté
Sébastian est l'un d'eux il a été
scientologue pendant 3 ans et a été
ruiné par cette expérience
[Musique]
moi j'avais 20 ans et puis de commencer
sa vie à 20 ans avec 150000 francs
suisses de dette je veux dire c'est on
rate son entrée dans la vie et c'est que
j'ai dû attendre de vente à 30 ans non
un peu moins le vent à 26 ans j'ai dû
rembourser mes dettes donc j'ai pas pu
faire des études j'ai pas pu choisir un
boulot etc et j'ai dû tout reposer ça
genre cinq six ans plus tard moi ça m'a
ruiné on peut dire un peu le début de ma
vie le sentiment de culpabilité ça
m'arrive encore de le sentir j'entends
Sébastien je veux dire
Sébastien j'ai eu l'emmerder pas
possible
c'est vraiment et en plus avec le
sentiment à l'époque de vraiment faire
des choses comme il l'a expliqué j'avais
vraiment l'impression je vais aider ces
bastions je vais je vais lui montrer
comment on peut être plus efficace etc
et jamais j'y pensais je vais vraiment
te montrer comment tu peux truiner quoi
c'est vraiment jamais été cette
attention et c'est ce qui est arrivé
quand même
on parle beaucoup de la Scientologie via
des stars comme Tom Cruise ou John
Travolta est-elle réellement dangereuse
ah oui moi je considère que la
Scientologie est dangereuse parce
qu'elle atteint profondément les
personnalités elle prend la main si vous
voulez sur les personnalités donc c'est
quand même
un danger sur l'autonomie
même si effectivement c'est les
techniques de la Scientologie permettent
à certains de d'être plus efficace de se
développer à un moment de leur vie mais
le problème c'est c'est je sais pas
comment vous dire autrement c'est ça
c'est de prendre la main sur la
personnalité la Scientologie est
considérée comme une religion notamment
en Espagne est-ce que en France c'est le
cas où est-ce qu'elle est considérée
comme une secte écoutez en France il y a
pas de définition de la secte et il y a
pas de définition de la religion donc
c'est vraiment un débat qui sert
beaucoup la Scientologie bien entendu
mais qui n'a pas l'intérêt fondamental
et au sens courant du mot secte
aujourd'hui et bien je vous dirais que
un groupe religieux peut parfaitement
être une secte et une secte n'est pas
forcé d'être une religion donc c'est
vraiment de distinction qui n'ont pas
beaucoup d'intérêt me semble-t-il au
regard
des préjudices de l'emprise de la mise
en état de suggestion sur les
personnalités vous en tant que
présidente de lunettes fixe est-ce que
vous souhaiteriez qu'elle soit interdite
non parce qu'on est dans un pays libre
on est dans un pays où on peut créer
organiser installer des groupes je
souhaite par contre que des les
atteintes aux personnes cessent ça c'est
vrai que c'est difficile avec
l'existence de la Scientologie et
ensuite je trouve normal que quand il y
a des faits pénalement répréhensibles il
soit sanctionné ça oui et c'est ce que
demande aussi des familles et les
victimes
[Musique]
la tombe sur laquelle vient se
recueillir Magali ce matin à Dijon c'est
celle de son père quand sa mère a créé
amour et miséricorde ils étaient déjà
divorcés en suivant sa mère magalie a
perdu contact avec lui il ne se sont
retrouvés qu'à sa sortie du groupe
sectaire disant après ben voilà on est
dans mon petit papa qui est ton père est
là qui
avec qui j'avais renoué des liens des
contacts qui m'a
soutenu et beaucoup aidé moralement
quand je suis sortie de la communauté
les Témo rock il était mon soutien un
papa et un soutien énorme
me donner de la force du courage et puis
et puis la fierté du courage Magalie en
a eu besoin pour porter plainte contre
sa propre mère une plainte pour abus de
faiblesse
je l'ai fait par colère parce que
j'étais en colère après j'étais en
colère qu'on me menti toutes ces années
qu'on mépris pour une andouille que
d'avoir souffert j'étais en colère
d'avoir souffert gratuitement j'étais en
colère de me dire qu'on pouvait être
mère et faire ça ses enfants
et je voulais la justice en fait
magalie a donc rejoint l'association qui
rassemble les familles des membres de la
communauté il se battent depuis des
années pour retrouver leurs proches et
pour que la justice s'intéresse aux
dérives sectaires du groupe fondé par
Eliane
et mon but premier c'était de que tout
le monde sache et que personne ne
retombe là dedans
si c'était vraiment quelque chose pour
moi qui était primordial que tout le
monde sache ce que c'est Tex ce groupe
et que c'était pas rose comme on pouvait
enfin comme ils peuvent le laisser
entendre et ça c'était pour moi quelque
chose de super important ça fait partie
de ma guérison psychologique et du fait
que j'aille mieux aujourd'hui
contrairement au jour où j'en suis sorti
et les mois qui ont suivi après
à l'aide Saint-Hélier n'a plus de
contact avec deux de ses sœurs depuis 10
ans malgré cela elle tente régulièrement
de leur donner des nouvelles par
courrier elle a par exemple envoyé cet
album photo à la plus jeune de ses sœurs
et j'ai fait des photos voilà photos de
son parrain avec sa marraine avec sa son
épouse avec le commentaire à chaque fois
la maison où elle habitait quand elle
était à Saint-Malo à sa Servan j'avais
fait ça dans le but de la ramener un peu
vers nous de lui montrer que nous tous
on était là et qu'on pensait à elle mais
que le temps passait et que mes frères
mes sœurs qui sont là sur ces photos ici
mon frère mes soeurs et mon autre sœur
prenez de l'âge sa réponse a été le
refus que voici voilà le refus voilà ça
a été rayé refusé j'en tremble
ça a été raillé refusé tu sais c'est
toutes ces années avec cette absence et
cette voilà c'est trop lourd au bout
d'un moment c'est trop lourd un jour un
jour on pourra le lui donner garde-le
précieusement parce qu'un jour on lui
donnera c'était ça l'idée ça fait
mal aujourd'hui ces familles tourmentées
par l'absence de leurs proches espèrent
un procès
car à la suite de leur dépôt de plainte
plusieurs membres de la communauté dont
Éliane ont été placées en garde à vue
par les gendarmes
son bras droit un ancien scientologue a
même été mis en examen pour abus de
faiblesse aggravé
aujourd'hui Magalie se rend à Paris
elle a rendez-vous chez son avocat pour
faire un point sur l'avancée de la
procédure
[Musique]
la justice tente actuellement de
déterminer le rôle de chacun des membres
de la communauté
donc dans l'esprit du juge il y a des
gens qui sont
disons
les chefs les dirigeants et qui sont
donc
véritablement responsable des faits
pénaux et tous les autres les membres du
groupe qu'on considère entre guillemets
comme des adeptes sans les victimes même
si pour certaines c'est des victimes qui
n'ont pas totalement conscience de
l'être l'enjeu pour ces personnes qui
ont porté plainte c'est précisément
d'établir cette notion d'emprise c'est
qu'on dise que la disparition entre
guillemets de ces personnes au sein de
ce groupe n'est pas le résultat d'une
démarche volontaire et voulu mais le
résultat d'une emprise le résultat d'une
manipulation le résultat de la perte de
leur libre arbitre c'est ça qui est
important à dire et c'est pour ça que
viser principalement
la notion d'abus de faiblesse
Eliane et son bras droit ont-ils profité
de la faiblesse des adeptes d'amour et
mis
[Musique]
éricorde avons voulu poser la question
en caméra discrète à celle que certains
qualifient de gourrelles elle vit
aujourd'hui dans ce village du Jura
encore entouré d'une poignée de fidèles
c'est vous lavez votre caméra s'il vous
plaît moi je fais un portail
entre autres sur amour et miséricorde et
j'aimerais bien
2007 pour le savoir il y en a qui se
s'appellent à faire le la méchanceté et
le venin moi je suis pour la paix il y a
des gens qui sont là qui il y a leur
famille qui attendent des nouvelles
depuis des années
les familles ne sont pas dans l'angoisse
rien du tout c'est un mensonge les
courriers se reçoit les coulisses
s'envoient il y a les réponses ou pas
réponse ces gens adultes et responsables
et je n'ai pas à justifier de ça c'est
des mentors
parce que c'est moi qui passe de l'autre
côté après
c'est la justice reconnaissait que
magalie a été victime d'abus de
faiblesse ce serait une étape importante
pour elle
mais quel que soit l'issue de la
procédure elle a déjà fait le deuil de
sa mère
même si demain je suis reconnue en tant
que victime même si demain elle Yann dit
oui j'ai dit les mensonges oui je vous
ai menti oui je vous ai manipulé je ne
veux plus jamais rien avoir avec elle je
ne pourrais plus jamais avoir confiance
en cette femme plus jamais
c'est pour ça que dans mon esprit je
préfère me dire qu'elle est morte
pour Jean-Luc et Magali dix années
passées dans un groupe sectaire ont
laissé des traces psychologiques et des
blessures profondes chacun a leur
manière il tente de se reconstruire
grâce à l'art pour Jean-Luc grâce à la
famille pour Magalie
que restera-t-il de cette expérience
sectaire qu'ils ont subi comment tourner
la page
[Musique]
ça a été comme un viol
et que c'est quelque chose qui reste en
vous c'est vous pouvez pas vous en
débarrasser c'est là c'est quelque chose
que vous avez subi qui est terrible et
que vous pouvez pas toujours partager
avec les autres parce que chacun a ses
problèmes dans la vie alors il faut le
relativiser se concentrer sur des choses
créatives positives mais pour moi le
bilan c'est que ça sera toujours là
[Musique]
j'espère que mon histoire et mon
témoignage
pourra les aider ou en aider certains à
ouvrir les yeux et à se rendre compte
que
c'est difficile de sortir de là mais
qu'on peut on peut le faire
on peut